deep in Northern Minnesota's
snow-covered Chippewa National Forest
there is a kind of Time Machine Steven
Sebastian's job is to peer into the
future it really is a world-class
research facility for understanding the
effects of
what we expect to happen in the future
within the forest lies a plot of
government land called the Marcel
experimental Forest where the U.S forest
Service and Argonne National
Laboratories have built 10 silo-like
structures inside researchers raise the
temperature from zero to nine degrees
Celsius to simulate different levels of
global warming
half the chambers also add varying
levels of carbon monoxide to mimic
expected future increases of the
greenhouse gas from human activity then
they watch what happens it's not
encouraging the trees are not doing as
well as they're doing in the unwarm
enclosures some of them are actually
dying from the conditions they're too
harsh too harsh for those trees to
continue to grow that's not just bad for
the trees Minnesota lies at the southern
end of a peat belt that stretches into
the Arctic its Frozen cover trapping
twelve thousand years of plant buildup
since the glaciers have melted
Pete is this like spongy
awesome soil substance
that can be thousands of years old
slowly slowly decomposing or as we think
about like climate change basically
storing carbon storing that carbon is an
important job this ground is covered in
peat plant material that goes down for
meters peat covers about three percent
of the world's land surface but it
stores a third to half of the soil
carbon in the world so as temperatures
go up it goes from being a store of
carbon to a releaser and that just makes
the world hotter faster
inside the enclosures it's already
happening we are seeing
essentially the worst case scenario
we're seeing what we expected
but
it's real
you do a little bit of warming and it
starts to destabilize the system the
experiment suggests that if global
temperatures rise just a few degrees
more enough to begin melting the world's
peatlands decomposing Peak could
eventually release more greenhouse gases
than they store accelerating climate
change and setting off a vicious cycle
of global warming John hendron Al
Jazeera the Marcel experimental forest
in Minnesota